[Music]
tell us what the show's like well really
basically the dynamic collection of
stories of my life basically just
talking about from the time i came out
of coming in hospital to um
meeting custom models to become a
champion it's just going to be a roller
coaster of just some awesome stories
they're all not going to be nice because
i wasn't always nice
you've been through some stuff and
you're going to you're going to talk
you're going to talk about very personal
things and this is going to be naked and
stuff
emotionally of course emotionally
negative oh oh oh
emotionally mostly naked okay you talk
about for example i have heard and no
one knows exactly what's in the show but
the rumors that you're going to talk
about your wild partying days and that
you're going to be quite explicit about
some of that stuff
yes i don't know if i'm going to be able
to say
the b word or the h word or the n word
so it's going to be i don't even know
what you're talking about
i actually need some of these words
spelled out for me no i don't but uh
but but uh but but what are you gonna
say i mean give me a uh a hard partying
story that that might be in the show i
don't know i might talk about a story
where um i'm at the espy awards and um
and i'm high i'm cocaine i'm drunk and
i'm driving my truck
and
the cops pull me over yeah
not only do they pull me over i stop you
know as soon as i see it like
stop i say oh
oh everything oh i just got beat this
one case for 11 years i'm gonna hit the
cop car and stuff and phoenix and stuff
but i was saying just beat
i was high
it's because i got it when i hit the cop
car and feeding it listen uh okay well
anyway
anyway when they pulled me over i said
it's over i just beat 11 years okay oh
it's over i said god man it's over and
then the cops said whoa mike man that
was awesome in the hangover that was
great
and i you know and i said
sir excuse me can you be like kind of um
um take me to this address sir he said
wait a minute and once he started going
to the car you know when cops go to the
car and they start looking at the
computer and they taking a long time
he's starting to say oh
yeah yeah you know when they take a long
time in that computer they're gonna feel
i'm mike by any chance can i see your
license i don't have a license office i
would have probably said right wish i
didn't but the cop said you didn't have
a license no um okay oh sorry
that's another story okay
okay no you're high you're in the car
you've been pulling
down when we hide right okay so listen
right
listen
[Music]
so anyway the cops take me to the house
and when my friend does the they took
you to the to your destination to the
drug house
i'm at the drug house right the cop
calls me coming to the drug house the
people see me the people in there
freaking out they're not coming outside
though so i go in after thank you
officer the officer mustn't know
something wasn't right with me because
when they told me to pull over and to
the side where i stopped i went on top
of the sidewalk boom boom you know right
there would have told you i'm drunk
right i'm sorry i'm on the sidewalk when
he told me to pull over so he takes me
there and then he starts reprimanding
the guy at the house to make sure i get
home and i don't want to hear anything
happen and stuff as soon as the cops
leave all the people the drug people
leave and say yo i'm out bye bye bye
didn't even see your mic man what's up
df yeah cause you're driving around the
police yeah
i was lost uh
and if i know if i would if i kept
driving another cop would have pulled me
over and out of men told me no no you
you did the responsible thing
[Applause]